okay so this happened I just need to say
thank you so much right off the bat the
response to my video yesterday far
exceeded what I actually thought was
gonna happen a couple of hours after I
posted that video
it went from a hundred and tan backers
to 325 and as it stands nine clay has
doubled his funding goal uh this is just
amazing
I really I don't know what to say just
apart from thank you to everyone if even
if you shared the post on Twitter or you
post it at the Facebook any of that
stuff especially there was you pledged
money this is the type of stuff that
makes me just love this community
because not only will people request
good quality stuff you're all willing to
put your money on your support where
your my Fez on dot is just it's just
amazing I know I'm repeating myself so
much in this video the last video was
the you I knew I knew what I wanted to
say and I wanted to let everybody know
how much I loved clays work and hi
worthwhile was to support him and I that
we've doubled his funding goal it's um
slightly unbelievable but not
unbelievable in a bad way unbelievable
in a good way I know everyone that's
pledged is gonna get some kind of reward
but my youtube channel is about to hit
three hundred thousand subscribers and
I'm gonna have some sort of celebratory
video planned in the next couple of
weeks anyway so if there's anything that
I could realistically do to thank you
all for showing this support because I
really don't take it for granted it's
extremely valuable and I thank each and
every one of you seriously but if
there's anything that I can do like I
asked on the community tab a few days
ago if there's anything people would
really like to see for a 300k
celebration so I might include
suggestions under this video on the
community top video the leading
suggestion is a Q&A with dr. Miller the
second most up voted is say hello
everyone my name is dr. Miller and today
we're gonna be looking at 300,000 times
or did dr. Miller origin story or till
the TLDR of this video is thank you so
much for the overwhelming support clay
deserves every single bit of it and I
really can't wait to see what he comes
up with if there's anything I can try
and do to thank everyone for their
support in addition to the rewards that
they're gonna be getting through
Kickstarter comment below and the
suggestions that get the most up votes
I'll consider but that's everything I
don't know how many times I can say
thank you but thanks again
and as I did with the previous video I'm
gonna leave you with a few words from
clay ah bleh enjoy
hey this is clay aply and I just wanted
to say thank you you guys did it I am so
overwhelmed by the amount of support the
project has received to think the
project would have doubled its goals
completely unexpected and I'm truly
grateful for it with extra funds we'll
be able to hire out more crew positions
which will make the process run much
more efficiently as well as extra
funding for post-production work such as
scoring and visual effects assets more
about what's to come will be posted on
the Kickstarter page under the Updates
tab you can also find updates on my
youtube channel Instagram and Facebook
page so be sure to keep watching I look
forward to sharing this adventure with
you guys Cheers
you